the last time I was in India it had all
become a familiar scene the rickshaws
rumbling through busy bazaars shoppers
haggling over everything from gemstones
to silk saris pilgrims prostrating their
way to salvation and street food
enhanced by locally sourced infectious
pathogens this time around I knew the
country had changed I wanted to see the
effects of 13 years of market reform and
hyper growth since my last visit
so I summoned an uber already something
new and I headed 15 miles south of my
Delhi hotel
[Music]
and as the crumbling roads of the
capital city opened up into a thirty-two
lane Expressway the old India that I
thought I knew began to look like a
thing of the past I had arrived in the
city of Gurgaon
[Music]
it's hard to imagine but 25 years ago
there was nothing here no high-rises no
kitchen shopping malls with Vegas live
Trump low ceilings no 27 hole Jack
Nicklaus Signature golf courses
[Music]
stretching all the way back to medieval
times Gurgaon was nothing more than a
plot of rocky soil with a small market
place and no railway link to the rest of
the country but Gurgaon had one enormous
advantage over other Indian cities it
had no municipal government most people
did not even know Gurgaon existed thirty
years ago it was a completely a farmland
on the outskirts of Delhi Gurgaon was a
sleepy dusty quiet town with lots of
agricultural land that was barren it is
KP Singh who started this company called
DLF and that company has pretty much
single-handedly build the city when
Delhi banned private real estate
development in the 1950s crucial pal
singh began buying land south of the
city limits his company Delhi land and
Finance offered cash and equity stakes
to farmers in Gurgaon many of these cow
herds became instant crore patties
millionaires in local lingo while KP
Singh would become the fifth richest man
in India by the turn of the century
acquiring land is a biggest problem
across the world and the government's
use their eminent domain powers to
acquire any large tract of land for any
development but here your case where
whole city has been built almost all by
acquiring land voluntary transaction the
province made it easier here to change
agricultural land into commercial or
residential or industrial land and set
up factories
[Music]
maruti was the first to arrive with an
auto manufacturing plant in the 1980s as
india step back from socialism in the
1990s foreign investment bypassed Delhi
and poured straight into Gurgaon when
General Electric set up shop hundreds of
multinationals followed suit soon
Gurgaon was generating middle-class jobs
by the hundreds of thousands today it
boasts an absurd 30 percent annual
growth rate and the third highest per
capita income in India under the shops
and establishments Act at that time
women could not work beyond 6 p.m. now
once that law got changed in Haryana and
very early it allowed a lot of young
women to start working in the service
sector in Google to work largely through
the night because we were matching over
times with times across the Atlantic and
the Pacific the first private developer
was DLF and DLF therefore took it upon
itself to build roads in go down to
later see wage lines to monitor law in
order
DLF in in a lot of ways set up its own
security even now you will find that
most of us here in Google hire our own
security and that is what keeps it
largely crime free while Gurgaon isn't
actually crime free it doesn't lack for
protection either 35,000 private
security guards keep a watchful eye on
the city compared with only 3,000 public
officers so why do businesses flock to
Gurgaon when taxpayers will pick up the
bills elsewhere it's high cost to come
here hire your own security bill your
own power plants extract groundwater
have your own transportation Google
didn't have local transportation till a
decade ago so it is expensive but look
at the other side of the picture it's
high quality because there is high
competition there are a lot of private
players you have very high quality
service Gurgaon services and cleanliness
are like nothing else I've seen in the
country
India's only privately run metro system
is fast modern and efficient employees
compulsively sweep floors that already
look spotless
it's unclear if Gorgons Metro turns a
profit but as it increases the value of
land owned by DLF and others it may have
already accomplished its mission over
time other developers have entered the
market competing with DLF and diluting
its share of Gurgaon real estate but as
DLF remains the dominant provider of
roads utilities security even India's
only private fire department it raises
the question of whether India's largest
commercial real estate company is
actually a private government we have
not allowed them to become private
government they have been sort of a
government within specific areas that
they have developed the common property
the public land which they have to leave
open for public infrastructure obviously
it's not under their control in google
it appears a little incongruous because
you have these neighborhoods which are
very high quality and then you
immediately step out and you see it all
disappear inside a compound of a colony
you will find great services well class
standards right outside that gate public
services don't exist so water
connections are very poor sewage lines
are not done very well it's in a sense
story of India frankly where the private
initiative has been very successful has
created world-class standards and
aspirations among the people right while
the public sector has not been able to
keep up with that the state was willing
to do just enough to collect the high
levels of revenue that a flourishing
town like Google could provide them with
but was unwilling to invest any of that
back into the city's infrastructure one
simple way to assess success is do
people want to go there our people are
going to go there willingly willing to
settle there open their businesses
invest large amounts of money in
developing those areas I think on all of
those counts google has been fabulously
successful while cities
blossom and bloom like this the flipside
is that they will have a tendency to
become extremely polluted and a tendency
to to to have large amounts of
population living in slums slums are
places where there is no public utility
we have no education no sanitation in
swans
[Music]
16% of Gorgons population lives in slums
like this one if that seems like a lot
to you the shocker is that it's less
than the average Indian city there are a
hundred and fifty million fewer poor
people in India since my last visit 13
years ago that's half the population of
the United States lifted out of the
slums India's achievements over the past
decade are inspiring but as my own
country turns its back on the same
global markets that transformed a rocky
patch of farmland into a metropolis of 2
million souls I can only hope that
Gurgaon has many years of hyper growth
yet to come
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]